der idiotische siegeszug der
einwegflasche wir schalten live zu
dennis knossalla der jungen die ecke
nebenbei einen kleinen supermarkt
betreibt denn es was läuft da eigentlich
schief bei uns super läuft dass der
deutsche liebt alles mit fand weil er
glaubt dass er damit etwas für die
umwelt tut mir der trottel
wer denkt dass er mit jeder pc branche
persönlich einen delfin rettet maximal
ein drittel wird wieder zur flasche
recycelt aus dem rest machen wir
irgendeinen anderen plastik scheiß oder
das zeug muss einfach als brennstoff
genutzt weiß er alles gar nicht warum
man schon weiter für die umwelt du magst
doch die umwelt wird pfandflaschen als
brennstoff ja klar
44% des verpackungsmülls wird verbracht
ihr treppe wir verbrenne ich verwirrt
aber in die recyclingquote mit
eingerechnet
deshalb sagen wir auch nicht verbrennen
sondern thermisch verwerten
es gab auch die hexenverbrennungen im
mittelalter wurden nur einige frauen
thermisch verwertet dann ist unser
ganzes system ja durch und durch
bescheuert liebig keine sau wir durch
mir persönlich ist es eher als zu blöd
ich gebe den ganzen quatsch nur noch den
penner der immer vor der führung
[Gelächter]
das sind die einzigen die noch wissen
was wohin kommt aber das allermeiste
welke
viele leute sind zu faul wie pfannen
flaschen zurück zu bringen
dadurch bleiben bei uns getränke fugees
im jahr zirka 175 millionen euro hängen
das nennt man den entschluss meine band
schlupf uhr sind meine fand schlug und
das ist meine band schlussfrau
wenn sie mal das ist ja alles furchtbar
hören sie mir überhaupt zu die deutschen
lieben fand wir haben hier immer mehr
kann produktangebot man kann jetzt
gebrauchte kondome zurückbringen windeln
guck mal hier ein verstorbener ein weg
konnten 75 - mit der kopf ist zu groß
nehmen sie mal in den arm sie müssen
nach stopfen der löcher stopfen
wenn es klappt aber da muss wieder
[Applaus]